welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul and here's some
superheroes dressed in red
that lost their vision today i learned
that something isn't beautiful because
it lasts
and sadly one division has come to an
end
that doesn't mean the kevin spoilers
show is over though and episode 9 has a
lot to unpack from it
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down the plot easter eggs
things you missed and a timeline on
where things could be going in the
future of the mcu
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you're living in a dream world where you
haven't had a chance to check out the
end then i highly recommend that you
check out now
if you've enjoyed our coverage since the
start of the show then please click the
thumbs up button
and make sure you subscribe as i love
you three thousand
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the breakdown
okay so episode 8 ended with agatha
revealing to wonder that she's a witch
outside the hex we learned that hayward
had activated project cataract
called that because cataracts turned
your eyes white and he had a white
vision
buns puns puns now what's really
interesting is that this episode really
cements how history is in some way
repeating itself
and there are actually several parallels
in the story to wander's childhood
as a kid she lived in this bubble of
sitcoms with her family
which we saw firsthand was attacked by
military forces that swarmed it from the
outside
this is very much been mirrored in the
hex itself which is a literal bubble of
sitcoms
that she and her family live in on the
outside there is of course the military
who are represented by sword
and they send in a weapon in an attempt
to destroy wonder and her family
wonder likely feels that her childhood
was the last moment that she was truly
truly happy
and now she refuses to go down without a
fight
that isn't where the parallels stopped
though and it was only upon re-watching
the series that i realized the two
villains of the piece
were perfect reflections of wonder and
her actions first we have hayward who
somewhat lives in this reality where
he's completely just in his actions
even at the expense of others this is
similar to how wanda changed those
within the hex to fit the narrative that
she thought was best for them to live
their lives
but in doing so she completely stripped
them of control
similar to wonder heywood has altered
videos to make things appear a certain
way
and both have a version of vision that
they've pretty much stripped of free
will
now their arcs do of course differ
towards the end which we'll talk about
later in the video
but there's also agatha who too mirrors
wonder
she's a witch that lost her family at a
young age and not having a guiding force
has potentially sent her down a dark
path
now in episode 8 a line that stuck out
to me was agatha stating that she could
be good
i think this is something that we'll
also see wunderessa with
going forward she's very much on a
similar sort of path to jean grey in the
dark phoenix saga
in which she's been granted a vast
amount of power far beyond her control
and this ultimately makes her very very
dangerous
either way it looks like the mcu is
shaping up to bring a lot more witches
into it
and right now i feel like mr dahl in far
from home
for science we're leaving because of
witches welcome to the new dark ages
we pick up immediately after the events
of episode 8 with wander and agatha
facing down in the street
away from the runes wanda is able to use
her power
however this was actually part of
agatha's plan and as we saw in her
origin
story the character is able to absorb
the energy of spells wielding chaos
magic
it's revealed that what agatha really
wants is for wanda to surrender her
powers to her
and in exchange she'll allow her to keep
west's view
wander things outside the box and
instead of firing directly at her she
throws a car
which i think might have been hers from
the last episode however this disappear
at the end
but the the scarlet clown it was there
for some reason
now shout outs to johnny wilkinson for
pointing out that this is actually a
call back to civil war
and which one it did the same thing to
tony under the house we see agatha's
boots
and this is a nod to the wizard of oz
namely when dorothy killed the wicked
witch of the east
so what's that make agatha the wicked
witch of the west
view hey now you might notice that
agatha has black fingers
and in fiction this is also the sign of
a witch
white vision arrives and though he
repeats the same greeting that hex
vision did upon materializing
it's clear that he doesn't want to give
her a big hug
i was hoping that there was still a bit
of him left in there but he puts his
hands to wonder's head like he's making
her an idiot sandwich
and simply tries to crush it we of
course saw a similar move when vision
did this to ultron
and it's clear that this is often part
of his plan of attack agatha shows back
up and we see one to say this is our
home
to which vision replies let's fight for
it this line is actually a call back to
episode 2
and which wonder said this is our home
now
i want us to fit in now throughout the
series wanda has done whatever she can
to stay in west view
and at this moment it's clear she's
willing to fight for the death in order
for the illusion to remain
this of course changes throughout the
episode and it definitely feels like she
goes on an awk throughout this journey
that feels true to her character jump to
quicksilver holding monica hostage
and i hope she doesn't need the toilet
because pooper's gonna poop now i forgot
to mention last time that the fiat name
could be a play on the full mccartney
theory
which states that the real paul
mccartney died in a car crash during the
60s
rather than continuing the band without
him it was thought that paul was
replaced by a man who had plastic
surgery to look identical
pietro being changed to fietro was a
reference to how
a quote unquote fake one replaced
wander's brother
and we were all just supposed to go
along with it now at this moment he's
far superior power wise to monica
and the double vision battle continues
whilst wander and agatha go head to head
now i love how white vision goes to rip
the mind stone out of vision's head
and this is of course a callback to the
way that thanos killed him in infinity
war
however he faces through it and if you
were wondering why he didn't do this to
the mad titan
it's because after being stabbed he had
difficulty phasing
now white vision attempts to force the
hex version outside of the bubble
as this will of course tear him apart
haywood explains his diabolical plan to
jimmy wu
and do this show being cancelled haywood
can edit everything together
similar to how wanted it to make it look
like the hex and white one were one in
the same
now hayward seems like a great guy here
but
the book stops at his terrible vision
pun
and after this i tell you what mate i
hate you
unable to woo jimmy he's thrown in a
barn but
due to his fast hands after practicing
magic not only has he nabbed the phone
he's also got a way to bust out of the
handcuffs the guy calls quantico
and we cut to wonder walking through the
town as well as the appliance store that
we saw in the intro to episode 3.
the mailman says don't shoot me i'm just
a messenger which is of course a call
back to when he said the same thing in
episode 2.
because of this i do still kind of feel
like he's the person under witness
protection
but as we don't get answers i'm not
going to stick my hat on that they
probably just forgot about it
now agatha talks about the dark hold and
we now have it confirmed that it was
indeed the book in the basement of her
home
this is an expansive collection of
spells that was written by the dark lord
kuthon on indestructible parchment
and agatha warps in whilst reading its
prophecy
now it did appear in agents of shield
but it now seems that that version has
been completely wiped in favor of this
and yeah unfortunately it doesn't seem
like they're ever going to be part of
the mcu again
i get a freeze dotty and you better drop
your fan theories about her being
mephisto
because she's a nice woman what what do
you mean i'm responsible for 90
of those theories get out of here now
after freeing the town of their
i'm sorry for all those bad bad theories
by the way yeah i'm really sorry now
after freeing the town of their illusion
they rushed to her and we jumped to
quicksilver's man cave to learn that
he's actually rough
ralph boner wait wait wait we wasted
this entire character on a day joke um
no i don't know if i'm feeling that now
of all the people i've suspected it is
i had no idea that this was actually him
and uh i suppose i have to give hats off
to marvel for completely blindsiding me
with that reveal
however i do feel disappointed that he's
absolutely no one in the grand scheme of
things
and it just feels like they dropped the
ball because it could have been somewhat
important
but no it's a it's a d joke i'm guessing
we'll never get this version of
quicksilver in the mcu now
and it definitely closes a lot more
doors than it opens
it was announced yesterday that the
x-men reboot will be called the mutants
and this was actually the original name
that stanley wanted to go with
so it seems like we will be getting
mainly recasts and potentially a new
origin story for them in the mcu
though that's pure speculation at the
moment and monica realizes that because
he's a real person
agatha has him under control and she
snatches his necklace which is the
source of the possession
her eyes glow purple when doing this and
you may notice that they reflect the
energy of what's being displayed
monika can see different frequencies and
this is why they change color depending
on what's being viewed
the townspeople poisoned by wonder's
grief just want to be let go
and she lashes out strangling all of
them it's at this point i noticed her
hand is also starting to turn black
and shout out to paul fox for pointing
that out to me in the promotional photo
for the episode
now agatha though often portrayed as a
villain at this point i think slowly
becomes more like the mentor that she
was in the comics
she clearly states that heroes don't
torture people and this makes wonders
start to rip a tear in the hex
so that the town folk can escape however
this also tears vision apart
along with her kids who race to the
square now you may notice that as
they're collapsing
they sort of split off into what looks
like terrorist blocks
this is actually a callback to house of
m in which wonder two appeared in this
way on one of its most famous covers
the hex has to exist in order for her
family to
and thus she relinquishes the tear so
that they can survive
this allows agatha to start absorbing
her powers which makes her body start to
wither
similar the witches from the opening of
the prior entry surrounded by agatha
white vision and sword ish goes down and
i got a lot of incredibles vibes here
especially from this moment
white vision blasts the hex one into the
library that you might remember from
episode two
and this was the place where vision got
gum stuck in his gears
he broke and therefore it does feel
quite fitting that one of the big fights
takes place here too
and all in all i feel like it's a great
little action scene
now while we're here paul i want a
bloody word with you
okay so yesterday paul bettany did
announce that the cameo he'd been
teasing was him
and as we guessed it was bettany all
along
i know a lot of people are disappointed
in this but the clues were there if you
are paying attention
and and what you mean it's my fault for
coming up with more stupid fan theories
look
we'll skip that now white vision's prime
directive is to destroy the vision
and when the hex one reveals he's not
the true one your boy needs some answers
across the town the family battle and
weirdly
dr strange never shows up now i was
certain that he would
and the fact that he doesn't kind of
breaks the universe for me
strange is supposed to be involved with
protecting reality
but my guy where were you yeah we were
all rooting for you but you didn't show
up now it was also thought that haywood
in some ways would end up working with
the avengers
but after he tries to gun down billy and
tommy
i don't think he's redeemable luckily
monica steps in and stops us from going
on to disney
star and she alters the speed of the
bullets as they pass through her body
cut back to double vision and they have
a conversation steeped in philosophy
similar to something that vision had
with ultron all the way back in the
second avengers movie
they discuss a method of thinking that
i've actually long been fascinated with
so i was glad to see something i love
finally acknowledge it
in layman's terms it basically centers
around a ship that has wooden parts of
its hole replaced slowly over time
the planks are taken from it and in
their place renewed ones are put down
however those original planks are used
as a way to craft a new ship bit by bit
and the question lies in which is the
true ship
something that we see both visions
reflect upon the white one is the
original
however the one with the thoughts and
feelings of the original is the hex one
so who the true vision is holds a lot of
questions
they surmise that they are both the true
versions and the hex version reveals
that it's almost impossible to wipe the
original's memory
which he then restores now in the comics
there was an
arc in which two visions existed with
one coming from an alternate universe
and the other having the personality of
a buckingham palace god this was similar
to this moment in which
there was sort of both important
elements of the character existing
in separate entities this allowed the
consciousness of one to be placed into
the other in order to restore the true
vision
and that has been changed slightly here
but it does hold in keeping with the
source material
white vision flies off likely to return
again i wonder does the speed sneak on
agatha
that we seen her doing an age of ultron
after filling her head with an illusion
we travel back to her trial
in 1693. though this haunts her
initially
wanda being a more powerful witch allows
agatha's subconscious to have the
witches turn on her
and they stick her on the pyre agatha
tries to bargain with her and exchange
her handing over her powers she promises
to hold westview in place
but wanda rejects this and the two go to
the skies wonder forces her powers onto
her
and initially it seems like she's
unburdening herself however as we
guessed last time
runes play a big part in the key to
defeating agatha
and it's revealed that wanda has
actually created these on the outskirts
of the hex
the runes themselves did first appear in
hexagons
and i appreciate that they turned this
full thing into a way to the depower
agatha
wanda becomes a scholar which after
absorbing all of agatha's powers from
the dark dimension
as well as her own agatha realizes that
she's actually held the creator
and i do get a feeling of regret from
her now i do actually think going
forward
agatha will fill the shoes of a mentor
figure to the character
she says she's going to need her and
earlier in the episode stay that the
scarlet witch's power is stronger than
the sorcerer supremes
making me think that this line was put
in place as she will be facing off
against strange
i think this may lead to wonder needing
to be reined in and
as agatha is a powerful witch wonder
will turn to her as a way to figure out
how to control the power that she's been
cursed with
or blessed with you never know now
agatha is someone who pretty much was
given too much power
but she never had a mental figure and
thus fell by the wayside
therefore they do share a lot of
similarities with branching paths
i feel like they mirror each other in a
number of ways wonder casts her in a hex
spell as the nosy neighbor
and we can see behind her eyes that
she's breaking but she's unable to break
this illusion
wonder attracts the hex and the family
head home and then put the twins to bed
now this [ __ ] now this shared bedroom
aesthetic is often seen in sitcoms
and it's a way for the creators to have
the good night scene play out with all
the characters involved
it's a really heartbreaking moment but
it seems like they will be back in some
form or another
but i'll talk about this more towards
the end of the breakdown now as the hex
strips back
we see the real west view which is of
course still devastated by the snap
shout outs to james on twitter for
pointing out that the scene in which the
pair say goodbye to each other
is almost shot for shot the same as the
one in infinity war
in that moment they of course wanted to
run away together but were unable to
and the hex has very much been the
escape that they promised each other
it culminates in a finale we end
like like ended visioned and though i
think some people are a bit disappointed
in the ending
i think it was important for the
eventual growth of wonder
one division as a whole was about her
running away from the truth that vision
had died
rather than facing up to the reality of
the matter she created this false sword
in which she was married
her brother was alive and she had a
family much like the one she lost
clearly she couldn't accept the truth
and any time it was brought up she shut
the conversation down
faster than you do when army hammer
starts talking about how he wants to
come over for dinner
topical joke there now wanda hasn't been
able to let go
and grief has destroyed her life and the
ones around her
however grief is simply love persevering
and the longer that she's tried to hold
on to things
the more they've fallen apart therefore
the only true growth for the character
was to accept that vision was gone i
feel like this is what we get in the
finale
if vision simply returned to normal then
she would pretty much be in the same
position that she was at the start of
the series
where she believed that magic could
solve all her problems
wonder states is a symbol of her grief
but also her love
which does feel like an emotional gut
punch he is a memory made real and it's
a really sad farewell
that will probably be retconned the
second white vision shows up
yeah you know it's going that way now we
cut back to the lot that vision bought
for them to grow old in
and wonder leaves she's stared down by
the townsfolk
who will of course always see her in a
certain way and this could potentially
be setting up how humanity hates and
fears the mutants
wander a moniker meet but rather than
being judgmental
she says that she can relate to her
grief after losing her mother
monica was of course trapped in the hex
too and it's nice that
she at least doesn't hate her as the fbi
arrive
wonder flies out of west view onto our
second post credits scene
the first one though continues in the
location with jimmy assigning jobs like
tommy lee jones in the fugitive
hayward is arrested and this is likely
something that would have happened to
wonder
but she's too powerful to take in i
really feel like this is where the
pair's paths diverge
and wonder being left to her own devices
could spell trouble for the world
from here monica is summoned to the
current movie theater
and we get a big reveal it turns out
that she's headed to space
as we learn from his scroll that she's
been summoned by what i believe
is nick fury now why am saying that
instead of talos
is because the former was in space at
the end of far from home
and we know from that film that talos is
on earth
in the comics sword typically operated
in space and with monica wearing that
symbol proudly on her uniform
it seems like the organization will be
traveling that way instead of staying
earthbound
we then cut to wonder in what i believe
is wonderful mountain
and this ties back to her comic book
roots as several of the characters that
she interacted with during the vision in
the skull at which graphic novel
originated from this location she now
possesses the darkhold
and similar doctor strange has a copy of
herself reading it
whilst her other one moves about now
this is of course
yeah you guessed it mephisto i'm just
kidding yeah
i just had to get that one theory that
one last theory in
no but what i believe is going on here
is that wonder is using the
astral plane to learn about the prophecy
as well as magic in general
if you cast your mind back to doctor
strange you may remember that he too did
something similar whilst learning spells
i believe that this is exactly what's
going on here i'm going to be going into
more depth on this later in the video
today
but i don't think there's actually two
versions of wonder
as we know that sorcerers can duplicate
themselves
from here she hears the cries of her
children and this is likely setting up
the multiverse of madness
both of the kid actors did post on their
instagram back in november
that they were in london which is where
and when that film was being shot
it was long thought that they might age
up in the series and
come the end of it the pair would form
the young avengers however it looks like
going forward that these two characters
will grow up along with the mcu
and they will pretty much remain at that
age that the actors are for the
foreseeable future
i think that wonder might try and bring
them back by focusing her power
and because they shouldn't really exist
that this will cause issues
people are already terrified of her
abilities and if she can bring people to
life that possess powers
then this will cause more issues i very
much view the next movie
as being similar to civil war with
stranger wonder facing off with a big
bad that manipulates them in the
background
but enough theorizing here i've got
enough wrong already
going forward though i think there's
going to be a lot of things that fans
will be happy about even if they're
disappointed in the show
and of course love to hear your thoughts
on the post credits scene
okay so that wraps up episode 9 and what
a bittersweet ending it was
for the next part of the video we're
going to be discussing my general
thoughts
before moving into where things are
likely going into the future
now this show is something i feel like
i've been totally invested in over the
last eight weeks
and i can't remember a tv series that's
had me coming back week after week
desperate to know the answers i feel
like there may be some people that are
disappointed in certain elements of the
finale
and that there will be a large group who
are unhappy that we didn't get
every single reveal that we were hoping
for however the mcu is an ongoing story
and matt shakman a director on the show
has stated that things that didn't pay
off here
will be discussed more in doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness
that's why even though i do feel
slightly disappointed with certain
elements
i know they will deliver eventually
because let's face it marvel are the
best in the biz when it comes to set up
an eventual payoff
i feel like i'm focusing on what was
missing now though rather than what we
got
and what we got was truly something
special firstly the show completely
nailed the sitcom aesthetic
and every episode centered around a
certain time period managed to recapture
the sitcoms that they were aping to
great effect there's a level of
attention to detail here that deserves
to be applauded
and i can't think of another show off
the top of my head that week to week
accomplished what it was trying to do
this well from a certain costume level
then there's the performances and to me
both elizabeth olsen
and paul bettany completely knocked it
out the park
they took two characters that i wasn't
massively enamored with
and easily made them some of the best in
the mcu
their romance was always something that
i was never too hot on
but that one scene in episode 8
completely changed my opinion on that
and everything just made sense this show
was incredible
and i think easily the most unique
property in the mcu
and also probably one of the best i
cannot wait to see doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
as well as the rest of the disney plus
shows as if they're all this level of
quality
then it's gonna continue the golden age
of comic book adaptations that we're
currently living in
now speaking of how things will be
handled in the future i thought i'd draw
up a timeline so that everything is a
lot easier to follow and comprehend
if you like this let me know as i will
be updating this as the shows go on and
hopefully by the end of it we've got a
big map of how every single thing
interacts obviously i'm gonna start with
the avengers
sort of being the nexus that things
diverted from
during this time loki stole the
tesseract and created a branched reality
which his show will be focusing on
that releases on june 11th and it will
see him working with the tva
as he cleans up issues caused by the
multiverse i'm using red hair because
it's a branch timeline and
also because i do like color ringing now
from avengers everything in the main
timeline happens the way it does
until we get to end game which is where
the order sort of changes from what we
know
from this offshoot we have one division
along with falcon in the winter
soldier which are happening roughly
around the same time
far from home happens eight months after
this time period
and i'm guessing because of the
cliffhanger that no way home happens
almost immediately after this
now one division sets up a big arc for
monica rambo
and it looks like she will feature in ms
marvel helping to introduce that
character and her power set
from here both heroes are going to show
up in captain marvel 2
which i'm guessing will bring a lot of
things together
lastly is doctor strange 2 and it's said
that elizabeth olsen will appear in no
way home
before she gets a far more fleshed out
role in the multiverse of madness
so that's the way things look in terms
of the branching storylines on disney
plus and the mcu
we also have black panther 2 the
eternals coming up but black widow
hawkeye and so many more things coming
down the line
and there's never really been a better
time to be a marvel maniac
anyway that wraps up the video and thank
you for all your kind comments and
support over the last eight weeks
i will of course be back to cover falcon
in the winter soldier
so hope to see you then and in the
meantime i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the episode and the series as a whole
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
on the 31st of march in which we're
giving away three copies of a marvel 4k
box set of your choice
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now
so that's you then message me on twitter
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the latest godzilla vs kung trailers
which will be linked on screen
right now we've gone over them from top
to bottom and pointed out all the things
you've missed
and also discussed what to expect in the
movie
if not well thanks for sticking with me
i've i've been paulie
i hate goodbyes but hopefully i'll see
you next time
take care peace